joining us now with more reaction
Florida congressman Ron de Santos NRA TV
contributor former Secret Service agent
Dan bond Geno I agree this with with
Gregg Jarrett David shown show digenova
congressman I agree with Alan Dershowitz
this is a perjury trap this is juvenile
the idea that you're gonna ask president
what was in your mind is an absurdity
and it shows just how far this is gone
from so-called collusion with Russia
where your rights on very few of the the
bullets involved the campaign it was
mostly during the transition and then
during his presidency so you have a
situation where Robert Muller he's a DOJ
employee effectively so he's an inferior
officer in the executive branch what
gives him the right to conduct oversight
over basic presidential decisions that
have nothing to do with any type of
criminal activity what was in your mind
when you talked about sessions resigning
or this or that he does not have a right
to subpoena the president for that I
don't think the president should submit
to those questions and I agree with
Allender switch and I agree with you
Sean I think really they're not trying
to investigate a crime they're trying to
manufacture a process crime yeah a damn
Bungie no no good lawyer in the right
mind at this point knowing what we know
knowing the abusively bias team like
Weissman and company that was appointed
by Muller would any lawyer ever let this
president go before this man at all and
the idea a grant the threats he's
threatening the president early in the
process when they hand it over and
cooperated and never exerted executive
privilege are you kidding me
Sean do you see the danger in this they
are not investigating a crime here
they're investigating Donald Trump
there's a difference that you know when
you do is I was a former federal agent
what you do is you investigate a crime
and you find people you don't find
people and then go find the crime I read
the questions and Sean these questions
are very strategic notice how they're
left open-ended now Ron's a lawyer he
can tell you this too this is what you
do when you interview people as a
collegiate you ask open-ended question
yes or no question clock let's time in a
/
trap exactly they go and then great
pointed this out Congress if there's one
thing that deviates and you're on a
witch-hunt
there's no prosecutorial discretion the
only way it gets that is Hillary Clinton
she gets a she gets a rigged
investigation the hillary standard is
not going to apply for donald trump with
robert muller and his merry band of
democratic donors and and people that
withhold exculpatory evidence like
andrew Weissman no it's he's not going
to he will be under oath unlike Hillary
he won't have a friend interviewing him
like Hillary had I mean at the double
standard is so flagrant here do we have
equal justice under the law congressman
do we have equal application under the
law or not enough this thing and just
think about just the fact that these
questions are being generated was there
a copious number of questions that were
asked of Hillary in her FBI interview
that was a perfunctory thing they had
already decided not to bring charges
coaming wrote the memo two months before
they even interviewed her so the the
lack of zealousness there and then the
overzealousness here i think is very
very striking I mean looking it should
be concerning to all of us that's one of
the biggest problems with this
investigation is they've been trying to
nail anything they can to the wall and
of course you and I and Dan we all watch
the Hillary case where they didn't go
after each bit they just session Huma I
didn't go after any of it and how does
rod Rosenstein be one of the one person
that signs off on a dossier mandated
application to a FISA Court when they
are lying to the FISA judges how does he
not recuse himself where's Jeff session
saying you never should have been in
this get out Shawn
rod rod and Steve was also the United
States Attorney in Maryland on the
uranium one precursor case the tedx case
this guy is so conflicted how he hasn't
recused himself or resigned at this
point is amazing he indicated a certain
age when he said oh serious consequences
if there's false information in a FISA
application well he signed one that was
not verified to corroborated and Hillary
paid for and they
told the judge he needs to get off this
case like yesterday
all right full disclosure I do want Bron
DeSantis to win and be the next governor
unless you don't want me to endorse you
that I will take it back